>> Tucker: IT'S ON FOX NATION.
HERE SEAN HANNITY.
>> Hannity: JOE BIDEN YOUR
PRESIDENT APPEARS TO BE CAUGHT
IN THE MASSIVE MIDTERM ELECTION
MEDDLING SCANDAL WITH FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AS WE NOW KNOW AS
CONFIRMED BY THE SAUDIS SENT TO
OPEC, WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
RUSSIA, THEY NOT ONLY DENIED
BIDEN'S NUMEROUS REQUESTS TO
INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION, BUT
BIDEN ALSO BAGGED, AFTER HE WAS
DOES NINE FOR THE BILLING TIME,
HE TOLD THE SAUDIS AND OPEC TO
HOLD OFF ON OIL CUTS UNTIL AFTER
THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
DID JOE BIDEN ATTEMPT TO COLLUDE
WITH THE SAUDIS, OPEC, NOT
INCLUDING RUSSIA, TO ACT IN A
WAY THAT WOULD IMPACT THE 2022
MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
SENATOR MARTIN TO MIKE MARCO
RUBIO WOULD BE HERE.
ALSO MAJOR HANNITY ANNOUNCEMENT,
I THINK YOU LIKE IT.
WERE ONLY 26 DAYS AWAY TILL
THESE ALL-IMPORTANT MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
THAT SAID.
26 DAYS.
I HOPE YOU FEEL THE URGENCY AS I
AM.
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING THE MOST
EXTREME, RADICAL, DESTRUCTIVE
CROP OF MIDTERM CANDIDATES EVER.
THEY'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA EVER.
AND EVEN FROM THE BIDEN ECONOMY
GOES FROM BAD TO WORSE, THEY
KEEP LYING ABOUT IT.
TODAY'S DATA SHOWS INFLATION AT
YET ANOTHER FOR THE YEAR HIGH
WITH THE SEPTEMBER NUMBERS
COMING IN EVEN HOTTER THAN
EXPECTED.
THAT MEANS PRICES FOR GROCERIES,
GAS, RENT, EVERY STAR YOU GO TO
BASICALLY IS COSTING YOU A LOT
MORE MONEY.
AND BY THE WAY, WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU ALL OF THIS
HARDWORKING AMERICANS AMERICANS
CONTINUED TO SUFFER, TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR SCREEN.
YEAR-OVER-YEAR, GAS PRICES UP
20% SINCE THAT TIME TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT IT HAS DOUBLED.
EVEN WITH BIDEN TRYING TO
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE PRICE BY
DRAINING OUR RESERVES.
ELECTRICITY IS UP 15% BY THE WAY
HE'S COMPROMISED ON NATIONAL
SECURITY TO DO SO.
ALL OF THIS IS CAUSED BY
JOE BIDEN'S INSANITY AND DOESN'T
STOP THERE.
HE LIKED MALCOLM?
MAYBE YOUR KIDS DO.
THAT'S UP 15%, EGGS UP 30%.
EVERY STAR YOU GO TO, UP, UP,
AND UP FURTHER.
AND WHILE BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS TRY TO ENSURE THAT
YOUR QUALITY OF LIFE, IT GOES
DOWN AND DOWN.
THE AVERAGE COUPLE, THE AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD, IS PAYING $7,200 MORE
FOR THE SAME EXACT PURCHASES
THEY MADE UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS LAST YEAR IN OFFICE.
IT'S ONE BIG FAR LEFT FAILURE,
ONE AFTER ANOTHER.
ALL PREVENTABLE CREATED BY
JOE BIDEN AND HIS CLIMATE
ALARMIST PARTY.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN TODAY, DOUBLING
DOWN ON HIS ECONOMIC VALVE.
REMEMBER AS YOU WATCH THIS
THOUGHT THIS IS THE SAME GUY AND
THE SIN ADMINISTRATION THAT TOLD
YOU INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY.
>> AMERICANS ARE SQUEEZED BY THE
COST OF LIVING, IT'S BEEN TRUE
FOR YEARS AND FOLKS DON'T NEED A
REPORT TO KNOW THEY'RE BEING
SQUEEZED.
FIGHTING THIS BATTLE EVERY DAY
IS A KEY REASON WHY I RAN FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
PEOPLE ARE HURTING THESE DAYS.
TODAY'S REPORT SHOW PROGRESS.
INFLATION WAS 2% OVER THE LAST
THREE MONTHS.
THAT'S DOWN FROM 11% OVER THE
PRIOR THREE MONTHS.
THAT'S PROGRESS.
>> Hannity: INFLATION IS ZERO.
IT'S ZERO.
AND INFLATION IS TRANSITORY.
RIGHT JOY.
HE JUST LIES.
YOU KNOW THE TRUTH BECAUSE YOU
PUMP YOUR GAS INTO YOUR CAR,
BECAUSE YOU GO TO THE STORE, YOU
SEE THE INFLATED PRICES.
YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS OUT
THERE.
THE AP HAD A POLL SAYING THAT
46% OF AMERICANS FEEL THEY ARE
POOR BECAUSE OF THESE POLICIES.
BIDEN CLAIMED IT'S NOT HIS FAULT
THAT INFLATION IT'S AT A 40 YEAR
HIGH, HE BLAMES THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE, SENATE OR WHITE HOUSE BUT
BLAME THEM.
>> THERE TO MAKE YOU PAY HIGHER
TECH STOMACH TAXES.
EVERY PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
HAVE GOTTEN PAST PEOPLE HERE, WE
HAVE NOT RAISE THE TAX ON
ANYBODY MAKING LESS THAN 400,000
BUCKS A YEAR.
NOT 1 PENNY.
I WAS THE MECH WISH I WAS MAKING
FOR GRANT.
NOT A SINGLE PENNY.
I MEAN IT.
REPUBLICAN WINS, INFLATION WILL
GET WORSE.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
IF YOU SPEAK TO DOMINIC DOMINIC
>> Hannity: PEOPLE ON FIXED
INCOMES, IT'S DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING MINORITY COMMUNITIES
IN THIS COUNTRY ACCORDING TO
POLLS.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
NOT 1 PENNY.
$7200 ON AVERAGE PER HOUSEHOLD
BECAUSE OF INFLATION.
THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
DESPERATE TO DISTRACT FROM ALL
OF THIS, HIDING IN THEIR
BASEMENT BUNKERS AND NOT ASKING
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMPLIANT
MEDIA MOB.
THEY TRY TO MAKE IT ABOUT
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE BIDENS
NEVER-ENDING SELF-INFLICTED
DISASTER BECAUSE YET AGAIN TODAY
MORE THEATER.
THE PREDETERMINED HEARINGS ARE
BACK, THE SHAM JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE, PREDETERMINED
OUTCOME.
GRAND CRESCENDO TODAY, NOW THEY
WILL SUBPOENA DONALD TRUCK TO
TESTIFY AS PART OF THIS SHAM
CHARADE PREDETERMINED CIRCUS,
JIM JORDAN IS NOT ON THE
COMMITTEE NOR GYM BAGS BECAUSE
THEY COULDN'T LET ANY
CONSERVATIVES ON THE COMMITTEE.
CHENEY AND CAN SINK OR BOTH
VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD TRUMP ON
HATE DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S A FAIR COMMITTEE.
SO I CAN SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S A DISTRACTION
AWAY FROM THEM AMERICAN PEOPLE,
MORE GRANDSTANDING 26 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THEY KNOW THE 45TH PRESIDENT
WILL INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
IN DOING THIS 26 DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION IS A DISGRACE.
THEY SAY THEY WILL RELEASE THE
INTERIM REPORT BEFORE THE
ELECTION, THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
HEARING ON THE 574 RIOTS IN
SUMMER OF 2020 THAT KILLED
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS, INJURED
THOUSANDS OF COPS AND CAUSED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE.
WHERE'S THE COMMITTEE ON THAT?
THERE IS NONE.
THEY SAT BY SILENTLY NOT WANTING
TO CRITICIZE THEIR BASE THAT WAS
ALL ABOUT RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF
2020.
NOTHING ABOUT THE FRONT VALENT
COMMITTEE HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH PROTECTING THE CAPITAL FROM
FUTURE ATTACKS.
IT'S ABOUT DECEIVING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, TRYING TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP AND ALL OF
HIS SUPPORTERS AND ALL OF ITS
ALLIES.
IF THEY REALLY CARED ABOUT
ANSWERS OR SOLUTIONS WITH DAVE
BROUGHT HIM MURIEL BOWSER WHO
PUT IN WRITING THAT SHE DIDN'T
WANT THE NATIONAL GUARD?
WOULDN'T THEY HAVE BROUGHT IN
THE CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE
CAPITAL BECAUSE HE REQUESTED THE
NATIONAL GUARD?
NANCY PELOSI IS IN CHARGE OF
SECURITY IN THE CAPITAL.
WHY DIDN'T THEY BRING HER IN AND
SUBPOENA HER RECORDS RUSH MIKE
WHITE IN THE TOP OF THE FIVE
PEOPLE IN THE OVAL OFFICE ON
JANUARY 3RD THAT ARE ON RECORD
SAYING DONALD TRUMP AUTHORIZE
THE USE OF NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS
DAYS BEFORE JANUARY 6?
ALL A SLEIGHT-OF-HAND AGAINST
YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
INSPIRE THEM TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE ISSUES THAT MATTER
MOST LIKE SURGING INFLATION,
CRIPPLING GAS PRICES, NO LAWN NO
ORDER, RISING CRIME, DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, WIDE OPEN SOUTHERN
BORDER AND SO MUCH MORE.
ASK YOURSELF.
WHY DO DEMOCRATS APPEAR TO BE
HELL-BENT ON DESTROYING YOUR
LIFE IN EVERY WAY POSSIBLE?
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WILL BE
DEVOTING ON 26 DAYS.
WHY DID YOU ABANDON AMERICAN
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE?
WHY YOU BEGGING NO STOMACH OPEC
AND SELL STOMACH SAUDI ARABIA,
VENEZUELA, RUSSIA, WHEN WE HAVE
MORE DOMESTIC ENERGY THAN ANYONE
ELSE, MORE THAN ANYONE COULD
NEED.
WHY ARE YOU CODDLING VIOLENT
CRIMINALS AND ENDING CASH BAIL
WHICH MARK THAT'S MADNESS.
WHY ARE YOU LETTING CRIMINALS
RUN LOOSE AND CARTELS RUN OUR
ORDER?
EVEN AS SENTINEL FLOODS INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES, KILLING OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE, OUR CHILDREN.
WHY ARE YOU ADOPTING THE
GREEN NEW DEAL WHEN YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO REPLACE FOSSIL FUELS.
THERE IS NO TECHNOLOGY OR
RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT'S CHEAP,
AVAILABLE, AND AFFORDABLE AND
SOMETHING WE CAN IMPLEMENT IT IN
THE NEXT 20 YEARS.
YOU'RE UNDERMINING OUR.
YOU HAVE ECONOMICALLY,
UNILATERALLY DISARM THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT'S THE LIFEBLOOD OF
THE WORLD'S ECONOMY.
I ASK ALL OF YOU OUT THERE.
CAN YOU NAME A SINGLE THING THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE TO MAKE YOUR
LIFE BETTER?
NAME ONE THING.
BECAUSE MORE AND MORE AS
DEMOCRATS DOMINIC DOMINIC.
REDUCE ENERGY SECURITY, ALL
WHILE WE ARE IN A MAJOR
RECESSION, STARING US RIGHT IN
THE FACE.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE OF DISGRACE,
SLAP IN THE FACE TO EVERY MAN,
WOMAN, AND CHILD WORKING, THEY'D
BE BETTER OFF IF THE COBB
COGNITIVE WRECK OF THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF WOULD STOP SURRENDERING
TO THE FAR LEFT EXTREMISTS AND
ACTUALLY PUT YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR US FOR A CHANGE.
STOP SPENDING RECKLESSLY.
STOP THE INFLATION.
RETURN TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
CONTROL OUR BORDERS.
JOE, THE DEMOCRATS, YOU SAID
INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY.
WILL YOU NOW ADMIT YOU WERE DEAD
WRONG AND THAT YOU LIED?
WILL YOU ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERY AMERICAN IN EVERY TOWN AND
CITIES SO THEY CAN PURSUE
HAPPINESS?
WILL YOU LOWER TAXES TO GIVE
PEOPLE RELIEVE?
WILL YOU ALLOW AMERICANS TO SAVE
MORE, GIVE PARENTS THEIR CHOICE
OF EDUCATION?
WILL YOU PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
INDOCTRINATION AND THE WOKE
AGENDA OF YOUR FRIENDLY TEACHERS
UNION?
WE PLEASE START PROTECTING
VICTIMS?
WE KNOW THE SOLUTIONS.
WE CAN SOLVE PROBLEMS.
WERE BETTER THAN THIS.
AND REPUBLICANS PUT UP WITH
THEIR COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA AND
WRITING, SIGNED THEIR NAME, AND
THEN HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS NOT LIKELY THE SINGLE
MOST CRITICAL INFLECTION POINT,
MIDTERM ELECTION, AND THE
HISTORY OF OUR REPUBLIC.
SO MUCH ON THE BALLOT, SO MUCH
AT STAKE.
THAT'S WHEN 26 DAYS YOU GET THE
FINAL SAY.